what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and also i just see jokes as the the
shell of a
the puzzle i don't see it as like this
feelingsy thing like
i have a joke in my act where i say it's
gotta be hard to be a kid now when we we
were so lucky as kids uh
i used to do it on your your your uh
tour there i'd say
uh back when we were a kid you had not a
care of the world you run the car and
yell shotgun
now the only time a kid yells it out now
is in a classroom and people were like
oh my god i'm like to me i just see
shotgun shotgun the word the joke clicks
that's
i don't see the whole inner webbing of
uh
people dying and feelings and parents
who lost kit i don't have any of that
to me it's just the puzzle part i had a
joke where i would say
where i would say we were at we had to
go to georgia's choir concert
and it was like [ __ ] four hours long
and the joke was
i wrote it the night the night we went
to the choir concert i then left to do a
spot after the choir concert
i said i just sat through a four-hour
choir concert and everyone was like oh
i was like yeah where's the school
shooter when you need me
or like even that's funny even the i
mean
i i still to this day and it's like i
laugh
i try to explain this to someone one
time i go what you find funny i also
find funny but what i find funny
you won't always find funny right like
things that make me laugh
are like really when you're not supposed
to laugh
like do you remember i could not stop
showing you guys the
the louis ck parent video oh man we were
dying
could not stop laughing yeah he
because he was not trying to be funny
and that's when people are of course of
course yeah that was comedy gold
it was when he goes then he goes this
famous comedian was
jerking off i could not stop laughing at
that and i go i know that this kid lost
a child yeah i can't imagine the pain
and grief he's gone through
i can't imagine the anger he had when he
saw louie joking about yeah of course
and that all of that coupled by him
inadvertently being very funny and what
is not meant to be fun i just it's like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] makes me laugh today i
was just i just said this together today
we got a new puppy and i was cuddling
with it and i go
and i was just loving this puppy i mean
this puppy cuddles
so [ __ ] hard it it is almost
i've never seen anything like it and i
go someone's had to [ __ ] their dog like
that's great but like i can't i can't
say that to like my wife's friends
right right yeah they don't get it they
just could be like what
the [ __ ] it's like that all the time
i'll sit there and go you think
pedophiles that [ __ ]
little girls make fun of pedophiles and
[ __ ] little boys like look at these
[ __ ]
gay pedos you know [ __ ] homo and i'm
like to me i'm like
that's an actually interesting thought
to me you know i'd actually like to have
a debate about it but people go
what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] but like to me
that's something let's
let's let's dig into this so talk tell
me about that when you got caught how
did you get
oh boy it was brutal man it was uh like
iphones were still kind of new
and i was in the shower and i was always
on edge you know like
i gotten almost caught like 800 times
but gotten out of it how'd you cheated a
lot
yeah pretty much every weekend you know
really yeah it was bad because we
weren't [ __ ] because we were
we were sick of each other but it was
still like you shouldn't cheat and
i almost got caught a bunch and uh i
would just deny deny deny
and then i'm in the shower one day
everything's going great
good relationship birds are chirping
sun's out and i'm showering up whistling
and my phone lit lights up on the coffee
table she's watching tv
and a naked picture pops up and it's
some blonde
chick that i banged who knows where and
uh
she i had no passcode then because it
was kind of a new phone
and i uh she opens it up and starts
reading the thread
and it was like man we did this and we
did that it was so hot and i want to do
this again i want to gargle that and
suck on this and swallow that and just
me
saying [ __ ] like i can't wait to do this
again and pull that and yank that and
fist this
and uh so the [ __ ] bathroom door
kicks open
she pulls the curtain back and i
remember being like hey coming in
and uh she just showed me the phone and
it was the picture of the naked girl and
just dropped the phone in the tub
and i'm like oh [ __ ] so i grabbed the
phone i jump out naked i'm just like
in the living room like hey come on what
are you crazy get out of here no no
she's not [ __ ] and she's like i read
the whole thing
[ __ ] you i knew i knew it i knew it and
i'm you know you're naked when you're
naked you look
you look like an idiot you know you're
naked and wet it's like the flip-flop of
sarah for getting sarah marshall oh yeah
there you go
so that was it after that and then we
tried to work it out but it was never
the same and
six months later was done yeah and i oh
sorry
we lived together and i just moved out
and i was like keep the place i paid
half the rent just try to be a good guy
out of guilt
and i just couch surf for like a year
really yeah i [ __ ] everything in that
year i mean i uh
i banged a chick in a homeless shelter i
was going on the road as much as i could
it was uh go back to the homeless
shelter
crazy store i was uh i met a girl to
show i got her number
we met up like a week later i went to a
bar called alligator lounge where you
get a free pizza with every drink
so i met up met up with this girl and
she's just wolfing down these pizza
slices
putting them down she was like a cute
blonde chick and uh i was like you all
right she's like
i gotta be honest i'm homeless and i go
what i'm homeless
so uh we started bonding on the homeless
thing and then she told me she's in a
shelter and i'm like oh so we're making
out we're making out and she pulls me
away and goes wouldn't be crazy if we
went to my shelter and i was like
yeah yeah go back to make it out go back
to making out pounding booze pounding
booze
before i know we're in a cab on the way
to the shelter and that's a funny moment
by the way being in a cab
to a homeless shelter so we get there
it's way out in brooklyn big stone
building
and uh she's like i just realized
they're not gonna let you in it's pretty
regulated you know
so uh there's this guy in the front you
have to like be buzzed into this huge
gate big metal gate that slides open and
goes
you know so uh she has this big hobo key
to the shelter it's like a key with a
like a hubcap on it and uh she's like
maybe you could go in and just
act like you own the place go in with
the the key and just walk right in he
won't have to sign in i was like all
right that's that's good
so i go in i go up homeless you know
tough
riding the rails you know i'm swinging
the key and the guy's like yeah yeah
whatever it's for in the morning
and uh she just walks in and goes hey
i'll sign in because she's actually
there
so they know her so she goes whatever
you do don't get caught
i'm on the third floor it's the women's
floor you get caught on the women's
floor you'll go to jail because like
you know i can't go up and rape women a
bunch of hobos up there you know
and i remember i walked in there was
this big pit it was just a big floor it
was full of people
on cots people in sleeping bags people
crying people screaming
people like kind of wrestling it was it
was wild babies crying it was crazy
and i go up to the third floor and i run
to her room and i open the door
swing the door open and it's got two
cots on the wall jail style
stains on the walls just shitty cracked
window and i was like oh my gosh she
comes in like 10 minutes later
we have crazy hobo sex we go at it thank
god i had a rubber who knows where she's
been
and uh the next morning i had this crazy
like
beer piss i had to get out of me like
booze piss so i had the big stomach
and i was like i gotta pee she's like
you can't go to the bat you'll get
caught and i go i gotta go it's an
emergency
so i get the key i run to the bathroom
i'm peeing and a girl comes in i'm in
the stall a girl comes in the bathroom
like oh [ __ ] so i have to sit down and
pee
you know so she doesn't know i'm a guy
and she's just dropping
[ __ ] soup cans in there i mean this
girl next to me hobo [ __ ]
and i just pull my pants up and get the
hell out of there i give her a key back
i say thanks
thanks for nothing i run home that's
[ __ ] great it was wild yeah
that's [ __ ] insane have you done all
your storytelling i did i bombed i i
feel horrible about it did you really
want that's the story
i have a it's a great story but had no
ending and ari was like all he needs a
good ending just don't worry about the
store have a good ending
what's the story yeah i had sex with my
screenwriting teacher and
uh i worked at a new york film academy
and
one of the teachers there it's a long
story but uh basically my shower didn't
work in crown heights so i was
i went like a week without showering i
smelled like [ __ ] my boss said you got a
shower you can't come in and so i was
going around asking hold on
you literally didn't shower to the point
where people were like yeah
it was bad take a shower i couldn't do
it because i was doing sets at night and
then i'd wake up you know you go get
home at three in the morning you have to
wake up at seven for work so
you know we run out of there and we had
no hot water we had no electricity in
our apartment every now and then
so it was snowing out it was too cold to
take a cold shower
and uh so eventually i put a [ __ ] pot
on the stove i boiled it in the dark and
i was like i'm just gonna take a [ __ ]
bath in the kitchen get it over with
the lights click on after i done
showering my [ __ ] roommate
cooked stovetop stuffing in the in the
pot
so now i'm covered in bo and like spices
and [ __ ] and herbs
it was too late i had to go to work so i
had to run out
that's what like thanksgiving so i
remember getting on the train it was the
4 train it was all you know i was the
only white guy and black guys were like
standing over like
hold on hold on sniffing me hold on you
took a horseman
the stove top stuff i put a pot on i
filled it with water and turned out
it was dark so i didn't know it was
covered in corn corn nuts and [ __ ]
cornbread so you're you smell bad but
now you smell even worse now i smell
like
a home-cooked meal yeah it was brutal
so now i'm desperate i get to work i'm
covered in this film
and i got like little parsley pieces on
me so i go up to everybody and one lady
the screenwriting teacher mrs fritz will
call her i go hey look
can i shower your place you go sure i
don't care and i was like oh my god she
was like kind of cute like 40
40 year old quirky weird earrings big
beehive kind of thing
yeah hairdo and uh she was like yeah
sure just come over but i'm having a
dinner party it's
at eight so if you don't mind getting
out of there i was like you got it
whatever
so i get there like six i bring a bottle
of wine to be nice
i get there she has a beautiful
apartment in brooklyn all
like a [ __ ] spread on the table just
crazy
set up dishes glassware the placemats
and i'm like oh my god she's like eight
things going on the stove bubbling i'm
like oh my god she's really doing this
so i get it i go hey look i'll take a
shower i'll be out of your hair no
problem she goes sure i have a glass of
wine we don't really know each other
i have a glass of wine we have two glass
of wine three last one
we're talking about life and love and
philosophy we're going at it
and i was like look it's it's 7 10. i
got to get in that shower she goes
all right all right well are you hungry
and i'm like i guess i'll have a bowl
she made paella i was like yeah i've
been eating good
in three weeks i'll take a bowl of pie
ass and now i'm eating the paella we
have another glass one i'm like hey look
lady it's 7
30. i got to get the hell out of you
you're having a dinner party at 8.
so i got a shower now it's like 7 48 you
know i'm like scurrying like all right i
gotta go thank you she goes have one
more glass
i'm like all right and she's like let me
give you a tour of the apartment
we're walking around our apartment she's
showing me knickknacks and whatever now
we're standing up on her couch looking
at a painting on the wall
and uh we're both looking at we're like
face to face and she goes uh you know
what and i go what's that she goes
i want you to come in my face i swear to
god
i want you to come in my face and i go
all right and now we're just going at it
we're on the floor rolling around
knocking coffee tables over
and all this [ __ ] just [ __ ] and uh
she pulled this string or something and
all the lights went out in her apartment
and we're just going at it it was
nighttime just hot dark
sex i wake up the next morning there's
blood everywhere
she was she was on her period and i mean
i just didn't notice it because of the
dark it was just
[ __ ] beat red crime scene thing yeah
and i had worked the next morning so i
just had to like so i went from being
the cleanest i've ever been to now i'm
covered in
uterine lining so i had to just put on
clothes and go go to work
and i remember on the way out she was
like don't you tell anybody and i was
like all right i won't and i
of course i told everybody right when i
got in but uh yeah that was it that was
my story
out of curiosity did we party together
in seattle yes
i mean i think it was portland actually
yeah we went to a strip club
god that was a great night and you i was
so hungover i remember i was like i'm
not drinking for four days i'm so
hungover and you were like do this shot
i was like i can't
and you're like dude i was like if i do
the shot i'm gonna puke and you're like
do it and i did it and i puked
but i kept drinking and then i saw you
at the airport at 6 00 am and you had a
beard in your hand
yeah still drinking yeah i was very
impressed yeah that's a yeah well
that's my mo i yeah i can't i
i can reward myself i get up early like
i got off stage at like one
yet yes two days ago saturday night or
sunday morning
my car picked me up at four and i said
okay if i can get like two hours sleep
then i'll get myself a cocktail and then
and then and i was like and then that'll
right the boat immediately as soon as i
get a little bit of a buzz i'm like oh
i'm fine
and so have you tried motive pure have
you heard of this
no i did drunk history and i was talking
to the guy who
i forget his name but uh derek derek
waters and he was like
i was like look i can't wait to do the
show but i gotta let you know i get the
worst hangovers like two day hangovers
they're brutal and he's like oh i got a
thing it's called motive pure it's they
give it to athletes to stay hydrated
he's like i haven't had a hangover in
four years i'm like oh my god
he said get him on amazon go nuts so i
ordered a bunch
i do drug history i drink like a third
of a bottle of scotch i really go after
it
and uh heard of a bottle of scotch is
that a lot i don't know i drank it it's
like a
gold label but i drank a lot of it more
than half and i really went hard because
i wanted to be funny for the show
and he's like here's your motive pure
and it's like a little shot i drank it
is this it that's it yeah i'm buying a
box right now
i drank it i can get it by tomorrow
there you go so it'll be good for your
hangover tomorrow
but i put it down and i wake up i've
never been more hungover i puked my
brains out i was [ __ ] blood i was
[ __ ]
i was i had a gig that night i had to
cancel the gig i couldn't get out of bed
i was like regarding henry i was in bed
i couldn't move my toes i couldn't get
out of bed it was brutal
oh my god that that that [ __ ] i think
you gotta like drink a lot of it or
something but
i i overrode it with the [ __ ] scotch
but try you might like it
mine is uh just say pancakes all right i
got lost
in upstate new york and i couldn't
figure out i you know didn't have a
smartphone i know where i was going so i
see this
black girl in the corner she was really
pretty and i go up to her and i talk to
her i'm like hey can you help me uh and
we're kind of
flirting a little bit like we're like
hitting it off and she's laughing and
i'm singing and zang and
and this guy drives by in a truck like a
hillbilly guy and yells out
pancake lover and uh i was like jesus
man you know i just met this girl
and you're gonna use the l word already
slow down you know that's an important
word we should bury that word blah blah
blah
use the l word do you still party oh
yeah
i had a crazy weekend in columbus great
city
oh uh funny bone yeah yeah great yeah i
just saw your i think i was there and i
saw your name on the
oh yeah yeah yeah i had a blab what a
fun town
they called the austin of the midwest
yeah which i don't know seems a little
weird but uh
good times great club have you you gotta
go to liberty township
i'm doing that in two weeks are you
really yeah uh i was just there
and uh i'll tell you the one thing
you're gonna i that
i think every comic notices their
[ __ ] sound system is amazing i keep
hearing that
it's the best sound you've ever had
great it's like you hear
yourself but it's not overwhelming yeah
i [ __ ] i love those those two clubs
because you can pack them out
and you can make like legit money yeah
yeah and
i hate doing the meet and greet after
but i just suck it up and i do it and
you get a couple numbers and yeah it's
uh it's a cakewalk out there in the
midwest did you get laid this weekend oh
boy oh boy did i
i mean it's you know that some
curly-haired new yorker shows up and
you look you look exotic out there yeah
it's a good time
it's fun so wait so yeah that's what uh
what soda was like yeah mark's numbers
are through the roof
well i went hard man you know i was i
never got laid in high school and all
that so i just
put my focus into that and getting laid
it's a real art form it's a beautiful
thing
yeah yeah so i just got good at it it
was like open mics i
got shot down for for months and months
then got better and better and then you
get on twitter i mean a tinder and
bumble and that's a game changer
you